whether you're into first person or
third person 2023 is looking to be
another great year for the shooter genre
here are 19 of the biggest ones that are
set to release this year
these first two games are XBox exclusive
day one game pass releases that have had
quite a bit of Buzz around them
Starfield and redfall they are also the
first two on the list that do not have a
solid release date but are still
confirmed for some time in 2023 as of
this video's recording Starfield is the
next epic adventure from Bethesda and
it's the developer's first new IP in
over 20 years the game's director Todd
Howard has described it as more of a
hardcore RPG than the Studio's previous
works but based on the Combat gameplay
we've seen so far shooting is still a
big part of the game those RPG elements
come into play in The Game's impressive
character creator that features a wide
variety of backgrounds and traits the
character you play as will also have
their own unique set of talents and
flaws based on the choices you make
around the Galaxy Howard also confirmed
players will be able to visit over 1 000
planets some will be full-fledged cities
While others will be procedurally
generated we still don't know much about
starfield's main campaign but we do know
things like it will be set in the year
2330 during a time in which humans have
mastered space travel and live in an
area of the solar system referred to as
the settled systems you play as the
space fairer after receiving an
invitation to join the constellation aka
the group of last Space Explorers who
are committed to unlocking the mysteries
of the Galaxy redfall on the other hand
takes place on Earth in the fictional
island town of redfall Massachusetts
this one sweet Community has become
overrun with vampires and a cult that
worships them now it's up to you and
your crew of survivors to find a way out
this group consists of cryptozoologist
and inventor devinder crowsley combat
engineer Remy De la Rosa ex-military
Sharpshooter Jacob Boyer and biomedical
engineering student Leila Ellison
redfall will have a linear campaigns set
within an open world filled with
optional side quests and environmental
storytelling borrowing elements from
previous Arcane games like Dishonored
and prey redfall will feature stealth
and immersive Sim elements however
unlike those games we're using the
environment to your advantage and
stealth mechanics are encouraged redfall
if the trailers are any indication seems
to swing a bit towards action-focused
combat but as awesome as those games
look let's talk about two games that you
can play sooner in February you'll have
atomic heart on the 21st and Destiny 2
lightfall a week later on the 28th
lightfall is the year 6 expansion for
Destiny 2 that features a new story set
on the neon cyberpunk city of Neo Muno
on planet Neptune where people who
escape the collapse created a metropolis
over the past centuries without the last
City knowing lightfall will include new
enemies and allies another Darkness
subclass called strand and updated
in-game features in an effort to help
New Destiny 2 players transition from
New Light missions into the rest of the
content Bungie is introducing Guardian
ranks this is a knowledge ladder where
players can progress through different
ranks that guide them through the game
according to the game's director Joe
Blackburn lightfall is quote the
beginning of the end of the light and
darkness Saga and for those of you that
have been following the story for some
time it's a big deal atomic heart drops
a week before lightfall which might give
you just enough time to beat it before
jumping back into the destiny 2 raid
grind I think good luck with that atomic
heart is a first person shooter that
takes place in an alternative reality
1955 the USSR defeated Nazi Germany
thanks to advances in robotics and now
the Soviet Union is using that Tech to
make everyday life easier that is until
the AI turns on humans just like it will
eventually in real life damn it a
computer definitely really hurt that the
gameplay of atomic heart has you firing
weapons with one hand and Supernatural
Powers with the other and true Bioshock
fashion in March you can look forward to
exploring the world of the day before an
open world MMO Survival game set in a
post-pandemic America the undead are
everywhere and the humans that are left
have become so desperate for survival
they're willing to kill almost anyone
for resources the entire package looks
like a cross between the last of us and
the division so fans looking forward to
the division Heartland a free-to-play
spin-off can get lost in the day before
while they wait for new information from
Ubisoft the only limitation to the day
before is it's only releasing on PC
sorry console fam the game also is
sitting at the number two spot for the
most wishlist of games on Steam at the
time of this recording so the hype seems
pretty real and if that isn't enough
zombies for you don't worry Dead Island
2 has you covered and will release on
April 28th this sequel which was
originally announced in 2014 does not
seem to Veer too far away from what the
first game was like it's a first person
open world RPG set in a zombie infested
Los Angeles that leans into over-the-top
combat characters and crafted weapons
players will take on the role of six
different characters with a respect
system that is meant to be used often
and easily to give players access to
many ever-changing character builds you
can even get bitten and harness the
power of a zombie which sounds cool and
scary all at the same time oh and by the
way no you're not crazy Los Angeles is
not on an island but let's keep this
survival theme going for one more game
because stalker 2 heart of Chernobyl is
coming out this year as well stalker 2
is the long-awaited mainline sequel to
the cult classic original stalker shadow
of Chernobyl from 2007 a PC exclusive
back then the game spawned two
follow-ups in quick succession first in
2008 and then one in 2009 stalker 2 will
see players once again taking on the
role of a gas mask wearing rat munching
Survivor in and around Chernobyl
exclusion Zone the site of the infamous
1986 catastrophe that has caused
suffering for generations of people who
were exposed to the nuclear reactors
effects the monsters and factions inside
of the Zone will interact with each
other in a simulated living world and
the studio claims events will be
happening constantly whether or not
you're there to witness them it also
promises a branching story with loads of
different endings based on your choices
and that its open world will be one of
the biggest to date if you're looking
for more ways to spend time with your
friends check out hyenas exoprimal or
payday 3. hyenas is a team-based and
class-based extraction Royale of sorts
from creative assembly that tasks
players with robbing high-tech vaults on
massive space Freighters sometimes in
zero gravity each match has 15 play
players split into three teams of five
and the loot you'll be stealing includes
pop culture themed artifacts the game
will be releasing on Xbox series X Xbox
One PlayStation 4 and 5 and PC and the
release window is set for some time in
2023. EXO Primal is a team-based
multiplayer game that has you running
around in mechanical Mech suits fighting
waves of dinosaurs that pour out of huge
portals floating in the sky in our
preview of the game last summer Phil
hornshaw wrote quote though we played
only a few hours and saw only a small
portion of what exoprimo has to offer
overall the game was surprisingly fun in
this technical test developer capcom's
approach to team-based gameplay uses a
lot of tried and true ideas borrowed
from other games to great effect and
fighting huge dinosaurs is just as cool
and pulse pounding as it sounds payday 3
is the long anticipated sequel to the
hit 2013 game Payday 2 and it was first
announced announced in 2016. the game
will take place in New York and will
feature the return of the original gang
from Payday 1. it will be available on
PC as well as Xbox and Playstation but
the developer didn't specify if that
means current gen last gen or both aside
from that there aren't any details
available for the game and the release
date is just as vague as the console
information and simply says 2023. if you
need a heist game sooner that isn't GTA
related then you might be interested in
Crime Boss Rock a city which releases on
March 28th Crime Boss is a first person
shooter with a star-studded cast that
includes Michael Matson Danny Trejo
Vanilla Ice and Chuck freaking Norris
just to name a few the gameplay reveal
trailer released in December 2022
focused on a co-op heist mission and
showed off the game's stealth shotguns
and ARS as well as the members of the
crew getting knocked down and revived
publisher 505 games and developer
in-game Studio say that Crime Boss
Rakesh City will feature a roguelike
campaign Sheriff Norris of course played
by Chuck Norris will be attempting to
stop players along with gang overlords
like one played by Vanilla Ice looking
for more of an old school feeling game
keep your eyes peeled for Warhammer 40
000 bolt gun in this 90s style retro
shooter you play as a Space Marine on a
mission across the Galaxy to defeat
chaos based Marines the game features
stylish visuals and based on the trailer
a kick-ass metal soundtrack on the more
modern side of things is Warhammer 40
000 Space Marine 2. this third person
action shooter is also slated for a 2023
release and sees you playing as you
guessed it a Space Marine some other
notable titles include RoboCop Rogue
City a first person shooter in which you
uphold the law in the crime riddled
streets of old Detroit wanted Dead a
hybrid shooter slasher from the makers
of Ninja Gaiden and dead or alive 5 the
finals a free-to-play first-person
shooter with destructible Arenas are
creators a free-to-play third-person
Co-op shooter that has you fighting
waves of mechanized enemies and my
favorite anger foot a fast-paced first
person shooter about kicking ass to
Kick-Ass beats which of these games are
you most excited to play let us know in
the comments
[Music]